it's almost six years to the day since
saudi arabia intervened in yemen and
created what is the world's worst
humanitarian crisis but now
the country's offering up a plan for
peace in the past couple of hours the
saudi foreign minister faisal bin furhan
has outlined a yemen
peace initiative that includes a
nationwide ceasefire
under the supervision of the united
nations followed by a resumption of
political talks to end the war
there would also be an easing of the
blockade on the port of hadida
and a reopening of sanaa's airport
however according to the minister it all
hinges on the houthi rebels
and whether they accept the proposal
we will work with the international
community with our partners and
with the government of yemen to push
toward this initiative being implemented
we will do all we can uh to put the
necessary pressure
on the houthis to accept and to come
to the negotiating table and to lay down
arms because we believe that a stop to
the fighting and a focus on a political
solution
is the only way forward we will
nonetheless continue to support the
people of yemen and the government of
yemen
and we will continue to protect our
borders and our
citizens and our infrastructure from
houthi attacks
there is reaction coming in from yemen
first the internationally recognized
government which has welcomed saudi
arabia's ceasefire proposal
the houthis chief negotiator those told
reuters the saudis actually offered
nothing new
and that it remains part of the war he
did say though they would continue to
talk to saudi arabia oman and the united
states
to reach a peace agreement here's
ibrahim freyja
associate professor of conflict
resolution at the doha institute who
explains
what's different this time from previous
peace initiatives
it's definitely an initiative
for conflict resolution in yemen i hope
it will work but
still there is a long way to go in my
view first of all let's
uh recognize that this is not the first
time that saudi arabia makes
uh such initiatives in the past or four
years ago
we have seen what was called ending the
decisive storm and internet
replacing it with the storm of hope uh
but unfortunately that did not work we
saw also
saudi arabia supporting the hodeidah
agreement that was reached in sweden
with the
one intervention that did not work
either it seems that this time
things uh different at least from the
previous times
and one major difference is that we're
seeing this time that we are seeing
a strong political will uh on the
biden's administration that has been
openly talking about that this war
must end and uh the two parties the
houthis and the saudis
are seeing there is a serious movement
is taking place here
and this could be seen in the escalation
on the ground
by the houthis escalating and attacking
of different airports in
saudi arabia and saudi arabia also
escalating its attacks in yemen in order
to have the upper hand
and preparing for the negotiations